all right
welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions if
you have questions
you are welcome to unmute and ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in q a session at the end second
today's gdpr seminar is open to external
audiences
therefore no classified discussion is
allowed so please watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it
now let me introduce our speaker today
today's speaker is miles cramer
it is an honor to host him who is a ph.d
candidate at princeton university
he focuses his research on accelerating
astrophysics with a.i
and he did a he did recently a
did a research scientist intern at
deepmind in 2021 maybe he can share some
experience
there with us today
today miles will talk about the problem
with deep learning in physics and how to
fix it which is very interesting topic
and these days
his research
is getting a lot of attention so
please
expect a wonderful talk and
now without further ado let me pass the
button to miles by asking one random
question as usual today's random
question is
what is your favorite things to do other
than research
i really like skiing i think that's my
favorite thing to do
nice especially this time of the season
right yeah
yeah i haven't been in a while um but i
i really like skiing
all right sounds good hopefully you can
you can get to ski yeah someday yeah
it's all yours miles all right yeah so
uh so i'm really excited to talk to you
today and i'm gonna talk about
um
a problem that i see with
deep learning and how deep learning is
used in physics
and and then i'm going to talk about
uh how we can go about solving this
problem so i i first want to know
i'm i'm not an ml skeptic so i think
there's a lot of ml skeptics in physics
and astrophysics
um
and
i think it's
easier to be an ml skeptic if you don't
work on ml um
but i just want to emphasize like 90 of
my papers are machine learning and all
of them are astro or physics um
so i'm kind of making a criticism of my
own research area
um so
yeah so
the problem
in uh deep learning is how it is used
for astrophysics and physics is that
uh i think it's well summarized by this
paper so machine learning the high
interest credit card of technical debt
and in this paper they talk about okay
machine learning offers a fantastically
powerful toolkit for building complex
systems quickly
uh this paper argues that it is
dangerous to think of these quick wins
is coming for free
using the framework of technical debt
uh we note that it is remarkably easy to
incur massive ongoing maintenance costs
at the system level uh when applying
machine learning so this is a really
nice paper it goes through
uh
how machine learning
causes you to accumulate what's called
technical debt so technical debt is a
it's a concept in software development
where
if you take an easy path
when you're starting to write software
for something then later on when you
want to refactor your code or add
another feature it might take much much
longer so this is called technical debt
and
i i want to
term this
as it's uh as the equivalent in science
scientific debt so
i think science is is all about
understanding things you want to
understand how the world works
how to model it
and i think when we use machine learning
to learn and exploit a pattern in the
data set
without
us
really understanding what it is doing
we accumulate scientific debt
so
uh if this if this model if you train a
model on something and you put this
model into use
and you don't pay off that scientific
debt by maybe trying to explain what the
model has learned uh this debt will
start to accumulate interest now
it is it does kind of nicely fit the
concept of debt because of course you
can you can take out a mortgage on a
house you can take on debt that's fine
but you should eventually pay it off
and
i think the same is true with scientific
debt you can you can use deep learning
on a problem but i think eventually
you should pay off that debt and try to
explain what the model is doing
so
i think
using deep learning without
understanding what it's doing i think it
will ultimately slow our progress
towards a scientific
understanding of the problem
so i think all scientific debt needs to
be repaid eventually
uh especially when you're using
these these high interest credit cards
like deep learning
so how can you pay off your scientific
debt
so
the first thing which i am against
because i'm a machine learning person
but it is something you could do you
could avoid the debt in the first place
and just not use ml so traditional
science you don't accumulate scientific
debt it's all about trying to understand
the problem
um the second approach which i like
because i i work on it
is to use ml
but in such a way that
all components of your model can be
explained
and we can reach a better scientific
understanding of that problem
so
i just want to
give a visual demo of the internals of a
neural network to
um
to just bring up your intuition so
this is a tensorflow playground it's
really nice web app
basically on on the right side
we have these blue points and we have
these orange points
now what we want to do is move this blue
surface
so this background
can you actually can you see my screen
my mouse
yeah yeah we can see it so you want to
move this blue surface over the blue
points this orange surface over the
orange points and so the orange
represents negative one blue represents
positive one
the way you do this is you
have these features so x1
is this way x2 is is the y-axis um and
so this problem is linear regression
so you have this orange line and that
means multiplied by negative one this
blue line is multiplied by positive one
so you wanna you wanna
find a surface that when you take
a number times x1 plus a number times x2
gives you this
kind of coverage over the points so
let's train this network
and you can see that quickly it finds a
good solution so this is
uh 1 times x2 plus 1 times x1
and you can see that gives us the
correct surface
over these points
now
what happens is if you have a more
complex like a more complex underlying
data manifold so in this case we have
uh concentric spheres of data
uh you can't really solve this with
linear regression so you see you try it
just finds this
bad minima which is just zero um
so it gets in the middle for both so
what you can do instead and this is a
this is like a very simple neural
network
is you can have these you basically are
doing uh recursive linear regression
that's kind of what
is
um so you
do a linear regression to this
intermediate
value
so there's three intermediate values
which each have a different linear
regression
um you then apply this this
non-linearity so in this case it's a
tange function so you you take this
output of this intermediate linear
regression you do a tange function
then
so we now have three features in this
layer we're going to do another linear
regression to the output
and this simple strategy lets you
express uh much more complex functions
so you can see in this case
let's see if we can train it
yes so it does pretty well it kind of
fits this triangular
surface over these points and you can
look at these neurons and see that okay
this value right here
is kind of like this edge
of the boundary
this this neuro neuron right here is
this edge so you can see kind of like
what this neural network is doing how
it's actually fitting that data
now
a normal neural network that you would
see
is kind of like this times maybe a
hundred so this is a typical neural
network
and so let's try to fit these spiral
points
so these these two um spirals
you can see that over the course of
training so it actually
it actually does start to fit this data
but
if i ask you what this neural network is
doing
um
it's
quite hard so you can see that okay so
it's done a pretty good job it's kind of
overlapped the orange surface on the
orange points blue surface on the blue
points
but the issue with this is
what's the relationship between these
what is this surface what is this
surface um
it's very difficult to interpret and
again this is a small neural network
this is eight neurons across typically
you might have like 500 neurons um so
it's really really hard to interpret uh
the relationship between features in a
neural network
even though we kind of understand what
this surface is it's just really hard to
understand how the neural network is
fitting it
so
how do we how do we fix this how do we
make neural networks interpretable okay
so so one solution
is to incorporate what's called an
inductive bias so
an inductive bias is some kind of prior
on
what possible functions your model can
learn so
maybe you want to learn a component of a
physical model so say you want to fix
lagrangian mechanics so you assume the
grangio mechanics
is the physical model and then the
neural network
you parametrize the lagrangian so this
this neural network predicting the
the energy the lagrangian
um
so this is one thing we've done
lagrangian neural networks
and then you can solve euler lagrange
equations get the acceleration
so this is one kind of way of making
these these uh deep neural networks
interpretable is learning a physical
variable
of an existing model and this tends to
make things a bit more interpretable
because
uh
you have a base physical model from
which to compare against
the solute the other solution which i
think is much more uh general
is to
kind of
take this
take this trained neural network the one
i showed earlier like the spiral
and and actually go through and try to
interpret what it's doing
uh this is obviously much harder but
it's possible so i'll show you how so
common strategies in computer vision for
doing this are things like saliency maps
you basically look at
uh
what part of the input the neural
network is kind of sensitive to
um and you can also look at
uh there's there's a strategy called
lime
which is similar
but there's a lot of problems with these
so
um they're
in many cases they're kind of arbitrary
they depend on your local optimization
surface
and ultimately
science already has a language it's
mathematics so why would we go for
a
industry-developed interpretation method
that is meant for like images of cats
which don't have a symbolic model when
we know physics has a good symbolic
model
uh which is math so so why would we not
use math as an interpretability method
um
so
this is what i've worked on a lot is to
try to interpret a neural network with
simple analytic functions like you see
in physics
so there's a algorithm called symbolic
regression
and this is a way of
systematically searching for equations
that that match a regression problem so
in this case we're using symbolic
regression
to approximate the internal parts of the
neural network
so symbolic regression it's another
machine learning algorithm
so given some
tuples like x input features y output
uh
you want to search for analytic
equations that can describe that mapping
so like if i have this data set so
x-axis y-axis
and i want to find what equation matches
this
maybe i would just go through say does
cosine of x fit this no does sine of x
fit this no exponent of x okay that's a
bit better
uh and then maybe i would start from
there exponent of x over two yes that's
the correct function
um
so there's a there's a systematic way of
going about this uh using genetic
algorithms
so
this equation on the left can be
represented as a tree
so this is a binary tree so the plus
operator is a node
uh the x variable is a is a is another
node in this case a leaf
um and you basically just go through
this tree and you
mutate it so you might say uh take this
multiplication change it to division
take this cosine maybe just delete it
delete everything below it maybe change
this variable maybe take this constant
0.32 and kind of move it
so you you're kind of iteratively
moving this tree around in equation
space
um
there's this so
one recent algorithm
uh
that works really well is called
regularized evolution
so originally it's developed for um
neural architecture searches which is a
way of kind of
uh finding better neural network
architectures so i i used the algorithm
for symbolic regression in this uh i'll
talk about this a bit uh i have a
symbolic regression package called
paiser so it uses this algorithm
um
and it seems to work pretty well so
in the in the original paper they
actually used it to discover
um
they actually discovered like a neural
network from scratch
which is really cool
and it seems to work for like general
uh programs as well as equations so
in regularized evolution
you have a
list of equations
you score them all so you compute how
accurate each equation is in matching
your data
then you take a
random subset of those equations
and you find the
highest score in that subset
then you take that
fittest member you mutate it
and then you you look at your entire
population
and you you kind of kill off the oldest
member so the one that's been in there
at the longest you kill them off and you
replace it with your new mutation so
it's meant to kind of mimic
uh evolution
like in the real world
but it's for evolving these kind of
trees or
program-like structures
uh so so
why should we do symbolic regression
so
again many of the rules in the natural
sciences are very accurately described
by
simple symbolic equations
so
symbolic equations they are
concise you can look at it you can just
write it on a piece of paper someone can
copy it
they are interpretable
uh you can kind of relate these learned
equations to existing physical theories
and and one thing we've noticed is that
if you if you kind of convert a neural
network into an equation it might
generalize better to out of distribution
data
than the neural network for physical
problems
and this is kind of like equations are a
good prior for physics
uh so
a bit of background so
uh symbolic regression for science
actually goes back to the 70s so so
patrick langley uh who's often not cited
in current research but he did some very
early work so he made this this bacon
algorithm um which could actually fit
like many
many basic equations in physics like
ideal gas law kepler's law
um
but these initial algorithms didn't
learn
uh
real constants
um there's a question in the chat about
cindy so i'll come back to cindy later
i'm gonna talk about it
so initial algorithms did not learn
real constants you kind of had to know
all the constants beforehand
and symbolic regression
it wasn't really popular for a long time
but
it's a hud lebson's group
with michael schmidt especially they
created this this algorithm called
eureka
um in in 2009
which really popularized it for science
so in general
symbolic regression it is
compact it's very interpretable you get
an equation as output that's very
interpretable and it generalizes really
well but
it's very bad at high dimensional
problems like if you have more than 10
features it's going to be really hard
to actually find an equation unless you
do some kind of like feature importance
step
deep learning is kind of like an inverse
so deep learning is efficient at
learning in high dimensional spaces
but it is
uninterpretable uh and bad at
generalization
uh for physical problems it's good at
generalization for like communications
um
so
the issues with historical approaches
with symbolic regression you can't
really handle high dimensional data so
like you get this combinatorial scaling
if you have like 100 features it'll be
like 100 factorial
combinations so it's it's really hard to
fit those types of data sets
um
there's some new strategies over the
past
few years that seem to work well with
high dimensional data so one
is cindy so this is by steve brunson
nathan cuth's group at washington
uh
so
so one so the thing the way this kind of
symbolic regression works is you have a
dictionary of expressions so maybe you
have x squared y squared x y and just
all these polynomials
and you assume your output equation
is a linear combination of those
um and you try to find a sparse set of
coefficients
for those expressions so it's very fast
um
and
uh many
many equations can be described as a
linear combination of
like a basis but the caveat is it's a
limited search space
um so some models are kind of very
nested expressions and it's hard to find
those
uh with cindy and you can't find like
real polynomials
um real real exponents okay so another
interesting strategy is uh from george
martius group
um
and in his strategy
you think of the neural network as an
equation
so if you could like if you think about
if i just wrote down the neural network
in mathematica
it would just be some huge expression
so
they interpret neural networks in this
way basically
and what they do is all the activation
functions
um are
are the operators in the expression
so like they they have one activation b
sine one activation is cosine
uh one is like multiplication
um
and
so you you solve the neural network and
you try to sparsify the coefficients and
this actually finds an equation uh the
caveat is you only get kind of one
equation as the output
um rather than like a series of possible
equations and you have to have
uh nice gradients so it's hard with like
power laws for example
um
so but i think it's a it's a really cool
strategy so the the strategy that i
developed and i i
uh i use in different applications is
kind of
symbolic regression as a distillation
technique
so
rather than
kind of directly searching for equations
what my strategy is to
first fit a neural network on a problem
so you have some neural network trained
for some problem
you just train it normally
um
but then you try to interpret the neural
network so you try to interpret okay
what has the neural network learned
inside
and what equations
are similar to that neural network
so
the caveat is the inductive bias of the
network so like
if it's a graph neural network and you
have like a sum
pool in the graph network that summation
operator is going to appear in your
equation
uh that could be a good thing could be a
bad thing it depends on the application
uh but basically you take your neural
network and you try to
uh fit internal relations in the model
so the so software for doing these so
pi cindy is the cindy algorithm
uh eql for george martius's algorithm
and then mine is uh piscer
for it's it's kind of like a
more classic uh genetic algorithm
approach
um
so in paiser this is one example of how
it looks you have this random data set
with a hundred rows five features and
say you write down your true equation as
two cosine x three plus x zero squared
minus two
um
you then put this in a pi server so pics
or x comma y
maybe you list your binary operators as
as plus multiplication
um and it'll do this search and so this
one is really fast
um it's maybe like a like a i think it's
like a 30 second
to find the equation and you can see it
finds the correct equation with
real constants
so this is another example you can also
define custom operators so in this
example i defined
special
operator is x squared plus y
and you can see it actually uses that
uh to find the true equation which is
actually some nasty
kind of cosine over x
0 squared plus 3. three
so it found the correct equation
so
what we did originally is
before actually applying this to
physical problems and trying to discover
things
uh
we we verified it first so we
we created these simple n body systems
like one over r squared law
spring law
and we we trained a graph neural network
on this problem
uh to actually predict the dynamics of
particles
and what we tried to see is is does the
graph neural network did it learn that
this law internally
so we tried to see can we extract that
law with symbolic regression
um
and actually see if if it matches like
one over r squared
uh i have another question in the chat
okay question when your data has
implicit discontinuities or is
functionally dependent chaos or
uncertainty
what approaches would you recommend for
teasing up functional forms
okay so discontinuities
i think
so i think
uh
i think both
my algorithm and cindy will work
equation learner will not work because
your operators will probably not be
differentiable but but uh piscer is a
genetic algorithm it'll actually
you can have non-differentiable
algorithm operators
um and as well as cindy
um
and then
for uncertainty
uh you can actually so
with uncertainty you could
either kind of smoothly interpolate the
data before giving it to the symbolic
regression or you could say
uh just just use a likelihood to
optimize the the equation
um
can the coefficients predicted by piscer
be spatially varying
or are they constrained to be constant
yeah so they are constants but what you
could do is just put in the spatial
coordinates
and then maybe it'll find an expression
instead of the constant and maybe the
expression would have constants in it
okay so
i wanted to introduce how a graph
network actually works
so
a graph network is a way of
fitting a neural network to graph like
data
so
much of the world is kind of naturally
structured in graphs
so like
like most of deep learning is just
vectors images sequences but the natural
world is not
it's not grids it's not kind of vectors
everywhere it's it's much more like a
graph so things are related to each
other
there's kind of like entities different
locations
um and i think graph networks are very
well suited for physics like particles
um
the way a graph network works
is
so this is a simple one so you have
uh in this case we have three particles
we have a green red yellow
so this is our input graph
and we say all the nodes are connected
so it's a fully connected graph
the analogy is like the nodes are like
particles then what we look at is every
pair of nodes
so we look at red to green yellow to
green
yellow to red green to red
so you look at both directions so the
analogy is like two interacting
particles
the next step of our graph network
is this thing called an edge model
and this is
a neural network this is like a normal
multi-layer perceptron fully connected
now
so it's like the linear regression
example i showed earlier
and the analogy is like this edge model
would try to compute the force between
two interacting particles
um
so this this is this computes the
messages between uh nodes in the graph
the next step is you do a pool you do a
pool operation
so the most common one is just summing
so you
sum the messages
received to one node in the graph
the analogy to physics is like this is
like computing a net force
um you then take that
summed message you take your original
node
and you concatenate them and you pass
them through a second neural network
which is labeled the node model here
and this gives you
this is like computing the acceleration
um and that would give you like the
updated nodes
and this is how a graph network would
compute the acceleration uh for an
n-body system
so
the way you would actually use uh paiser
here or like use symbolic regression
here
is to take this edge model
which is the same edge model for each
pair
take that edge model
and you try to fit it with symbolic
regression
you do the same for the node model you
try to fit it with symbolic regression
and and that kind of gives you an
equation representation of what the
graph network is like
now the difference between this and
newtonian mechanics is that
your messages
are actually very high dimensional like
they could be a hundred dimensions
that's because you don't want to
actually
uh
tell it to have like three dimensions
like newtonian mechanics like you don't
know how many dimensions these messages
could have
um
so what you do during training
is to encourage sparsity on these
messages
to make
to basically
allow for fewer equations in the output
um
are there any questions about this
because i feel like graph networks are
always a bit tricky to understand so
feel free to ask questions in the chat
or
over audio as well
um
okay so
so
here's one example of how you would
actually train this graph network
and try to extract the knowledge it's
learned so in this case we're going to
generate some simulations of particles
connected by springs
with a with a one
kind of resting position
so we learn to predict these dynamics
with a graph network
see over time they get closer and closer
and closer so the graph network has
learned to be kind of an accurate
physical simulator
now what we do and this is the this is
the added part
is to
apply an l1 loss to the message vectors
and that encourages all the information
to be in as few
components as possible so you see here
it's only used using about two
dimensions um
and that makes it much much easier to
interpret
so you then try to fit
uh so in this example we know the force
we can kind of compare the true force
with the internal
uh message
and what we found is that
this internal message
is
very tightly correlated
uh with the
with the actual forces in the system so
by kind of regularizing the amount of
information in the messages we've kind
of forced it to find
uh
the true newtonian force
um and then so what you can do if you
don't know the force
is to
uh to basically
start
if you don't know the force you can
fit these messages with symbolic
regression um
okay so
one
problem
with
uh that's still present in this type of
approach
does anybody use these tools to solve
the three-body problem in celestial
mechanics
um
i guess it depends
what you mean so if
if you mean predicting the
uh long-term evolution of a three-body
system
uh
no i haven't seen anybody try that
so we have another
so i have another paper that
is the uh
it solves uh
the stability problem of three planets
around a star you try to predict when
the system is going to go unstable you
can do that with a deep neural network
but we haven't actually tried to
uh use symbolic regression yet
um but i think that could be really
interesting
yeah there's no there's no close
solution to the three-body problem but
you would basically find an
approximation of it
because
in compact three planet systems it's
chaotic but the chaos is is uh
constrained
so
you can actually predict like the
interval when a plan when a system is
going to go unstable
anyways
so
okay
one problem is
what if we have many features in our in
our data set
so
the a genetic
algorithm-based
symbolic regression still scales really
badly with the number of input features
so
what we want to do is instead of just
trying to predict
all the relations between this input
layer and this output layer in a neural
network and try to modeling it with the
with a symbolic regression
what we try to do
is limit the number of dependencies of
every output
so
we call this disentangled sparsity
basically you want every output feature
to depend on as few inputs as possible
so you see this this top feature here
depends on only these features this one
only depends on these features
and these are learned during training
the reason you want to do this is
because
then the relationship between these
inputs and this output feature
is is much easier to interpret because
it's just it's just a function of two
variables
uh whereas if you had maybe like 10
input features it would be a lot harder
to understand
so
the way you can actually do this is to
basically sparsify
the jacobian matrix of a neural network
um
i won't go into the details but
say we had this mapping and this is a
this is a fluid system
um
and what we're trying to do here is take
these input features and map it to a
latent encoding inside the neural
network
the problem is
every like there's 20 output features
and every single output feature depends
on so many input features
um so it's really hard to learn this
mapping
with with kind of a symbolic regression
approach like every equation would just
be
huge dependent on so many variables it
would be really hard to interpret even
if you did do symbolic regression
so what you can do with this algorithm
is you make
uh
you basically ask the algorithm to give
you as few output features as possible
so you see we only have three important
ones
and of those
every output feature should depend on as
few inputs as possible so you can see
output features zero depends on only vx
density
and displacement in the x direction
this is much easier to interpret and if
you extract an equation for this
um it'll be much
easier to interpret
uh
okay question from the chat uh disa
disentanglement and drop out can they be
related
uh it is kind of similar
in that
this sparse mask here
is is kind of like you're dropping those
neurons the difference is those are
those are the permanent drops like you
exclude those variables completely
whereas dropout is a training technique
to kind of randomly drop
features um
so
yeah so this is much easier
if you have many input features it's
much easier to kind of make every output
depend on as few inputs as possible
uh and you would you kind of fit
separate equations to both
so
the
the question we're really interested in
is these are nice nice methods but can
we actually apply them to real problems
so
the first example we looked at is uh
is
dark matter cosmology
so we want to see can we predict the
density
of dark matter
in a
in a region of space
by knowing the surrounding
uh dark matter environment so if we give
the dark matter environment to a graph
network can it predict the dark matter
density
at the center of the of this
surroundings
after we do this can we extract symbolic
equations from that model and try to get
an analytic representation of of what
it's actually learned
so the problem set up is to actually
treat
uh so you treat these these dark matter
halos as nodes in your graph
and you you kind of connect them to the
nearest node
so we go through this so we have this
dark matter simulation for a given
cosmology
uh predict density given the surrounding
dark matter halos
again you do this low dimensionality
uh regularization
and what we found is you find you get
this equation so it is
uh
it's a sum of masses of the surrounding
uh dark matter halos divided by this
kind of distance scaling so this
basically tells us it's dependent on how
much mass is around it with this uh
distance
kind of drop off so as you go farther
away
uh it depends less and less
and the interesting thing is we actually
divide by the mass of the center halo
which is a bit unintuitive
and
while there's not it is kind of hard to
reason about
why this particular equation would would
be like this um we've thought about it a
bit but the really important thing is
that we can actually we can actually
discuss
what this model has learned if this
model was stuck inside that graph
network we would have no idea what it
had learned and we would basically just
be taking it like a black box but we can
actually discuss this and say okay maybe
c4 is like
maybe it's like the gas mask or
something
so yeah so we found the solution it
gives actually much better performance
than existing
uh kind of simple physical models
um and it's very interpretable very
compact
uh another thing we tested is like
if you mask
uh maybe 20 of the data in your training
set
of the dark matter distribution
you train that graph network again
and you do the symbolic regression again
what we found is the symbolic expression
generalizes much better to
the heavier dark matter
than the graph neural network
so it's kind of like symbolic
expressions are a much better
prior on function space
for uh physical problems which is really
interesting and i think it's very
important uh for us to kind of
go to analytic expressions
uh we've applied this to other examples
recently so this is with christina
kreisch who recently graduated
um
we tried to see if we can find a better
uh
what's called a dark matter void so it's
like an absence of of dark matter
these huge holes
in large scale structure
we try to see is there a better way we
can actually map these
these voids to
um
to
predicting cosmological variables
so
yeah we you can read more about it in
this uh simdeal workshop we basically
created this
uh
thing that is like a
because like a normal cosmology model
and
we actually found this relationship
between dark matter void radius density
uh
and ellipticity
to the the cosmology variable
so so normally you just relate the void
radius
to the cosmology variable but this this
model actually relates the density
contrast and ellipticity and it was
really cool that the the graph network
kind of just discovered this
um
another example we've looked at is
uh
actually i think
the really nice way to pose this problem
is like
if deep learning was around in the time
of kepler
would kepler have found kepler's laws
and would newton have actually
discovered newtonian mechanics or would
they just have fit deep learning to
everything and just been satisfied with
the predictions
uh so someone asked this at a talk
someone else's talk actually
um but i think that
symbolic regression is actually really
i think it kind of
prevents that problem i think if you can
interpret a neural network with symbolic
regression you can actually get an
interpretation of
so we tried to apply this to
uh ephemeris data which is the motions
of everybody in the solar system we try
to see
can we discover
newton's law of gravity
just from solar system dynamics data
the other thing we did is we didn't tell
it the masses of the uh
planets in the solar system
so this model had to both learn
the masses of every single body in the
solar system
and learn newton's law of gravity
um
so
because if you give it the masses it's
kind of like cheating it's maybe too
easy for it but it has to learn both the
mass of every single body and newton's
law of gravity
and
so it actually it actually worked and it
found the correct mass in many different
cases so many different moons planets
it finds a very accurate mass it
actually found the gravitational
constant
uh to a few decimal points
um
the planets it didn't or the moons it
didn't get very high accuracy it's
because we found that they kind of had
very low gravitational influence on
other bodies so that they were just not
well constrained
but it was really cool to see that we
can discover newton's law of gravity and
kind of hidden
uh hidden
physical variables in the system
without
kind of telling it what those physical
variables are
another example is we tried
for fluid dynamics we actually extracted
the
euler equations
from that graph network there's a couple
mistakes so
instead of density it actually started
using pressure in a lot of cases
and i think that's from the data set
itself it was just pressure and density
were like very correlated in the data
set and it just found a way to kind of
find a simpler equation that works
um
okay couple questions
the 2009 science paper by libsyn
extracts physical laws without neural
networks
yes so they have low dimensional data
sets
but it's much harder to use this on high
dimensional data sets i think there is
where you really need neural networks
i have a slide at the end where i kind
of make this quantitative
another question were you able to come
up with uncertainties
on the inverse square law for gravity
i think we actually
uh
so this paper is being submitted soon
uh so basically
yeah these are the uncertainties
on the masses and that uncertainty
estimate is just based on rerunning the
model over and over
uh i think we have air bar on the
gravitational constant but i'll double
check that
uh
if you mean on the actual symbolic law
we we have a list of equations that it's
discovered
but we don't have an actual uncertainty
on the symbolic form i think that's a
really interesting
question um
so there's a additional recent
applications by other people so this is
uh anna maria delgado who's at harvard
uh
they found this halo occupation
distribution function
analytically
using paiser
another paper
which looked at lhc data
they used something called some
simulation based inference
and they tried to understand what the
simulation based infants has learned uh
analytically so i think that one is
really interesting another one
this is like a string theory paper they
they tried to use my symbolic regression
distillation technique
to find the hyperbolic volume of a knot
which was kind of first learned by a
neural network and then they extract it
so
summary when we use
deep learning to kind of learn a
physical problem
uh i think we are postponing our need to
understand that problem um so i i really
think
we should not use deep learning in the
way that industry uses it which is kind
of a quick and easy solution to a
complicated problem i really think we
should try to use deep learning to help
us learn something new because it's very
good at high dimensional
uh
regression problems i think we should
exploit that and try to
use it as a as a science tool
um
yeah so so that's
the conclusion of my talk
i'm happy to take questions and i see
there's some questions in the chat that
i can also answer
uh yeah thanks again for inviting me
thank you thank you so much miles that
was a wonderful talk and very
interesting um there were um you know as
you mentioned um you know there were
some questions in the chat
box which which was not answered by you
i mean you did a really good job
answering those questions spontaneously
but there were some of them which you
haven't answered so first one is
by tanim
and she was wondering um if you can
apply the sr the symbol regression
the stuff like orbital resonances and
lagrange points
you can answer that question
uh
it depends kind of what
they mean
uh
i guess
oh one thing people have asked me about
a lot is can you use this to find um
cons uh
conserved constants in a physical system
um
and i think that is really interesting
so you know given some dynamical system
what constants are conserved
and i think you can also do this with a
neural network combined with symbolic
regression approach where you kind of
use the neural network to learn
constants of motion the way you can do
that
is you basically optimize
you try to make your constants of motion
constant over a single trajectory
but different over different
trajectories
and then the neural network can
basically use that to find constants of
motion
and then you would basically apply
symbolic regression at the end
okay sounds good uh the next question by
tom
he said i'm not sure about the exact
algorithms about uh
for
symbol regressions but why don't we
apply a simple regression to fit the
original data directly rather than
fit the bidding of the neural network
yeah this is a really good question uh
so
if you fit
uh
to a say say you're searching for a
model which is two parts there's like
one equation
and then the internal like the kind of
inside equation is summed over a
sequence
so
say that each part of this equation
requires you search ten to the nine
possible equations
now
if you try to do symbolic regression on
the entire thing and you search for ten
to the nine equations on the out part
ten to the nine equations on the inside
part
that means there's 10 to the 18 possible
equations
whereas
if you do this with a neural network
you fit both parts simultaneously neural
networks are very fast to train then you
separate these
then you fit ten to the nine equations
on this one ten to the nine equations on
this one
that's two times ten to the nine
equations so you've reduced your search
space from ten to the eighteen equations
with just pure symbolic regression to 2
times 10 to the nine equations with
this
combination approach so it it's all
about reducing
the load on symbolic regression if it's
just like simple three variable to one
variable yes do symbolic regression by
itself but if it's a high dimensional
system
you really need to use deep learning to
reduce
your space
okay uh well actually
that's um
you know raised uh that's related to
the question i was about to ask um
how high dimensional um
the data have you
um
you know apply this symbol regressions
um using the neural net
the framework what's the biggest
the problem size you have solved so
the
the dark matter simulation is actually
100 thousand times
like seven features
so it's 700 000 features but the the way
you've reduced that is with a graph
network which
um
it kind of reduces the functional form
to be
local
um
and it it so that by just by imposing
that inductive bias you're already
simplifying the problem a lot
to a lower dimensional space it's still
high dimensional so you might have maybe
uh 20 times seven features
and then by composing it with this node
model and edge model
you reduce it to like pairs of nodes so
that would just be like seven times two
features
that's that's impressive okay
all right uh next questions uh by
european who
he asked will the model convert to the
same equation given different initial
conditions ah that's a really good
question so no
so
there's often a degeneracy
if you're learning
the model in two parts there's often a
degeneracy
for example in the problem where you're
learning a force law
what the neural network can do
because neural networks are
very tricky
is the first neural network can learn an
arbitrary rotation the second neural
network rotates it back
that rotation is completely arbitrary
and there's nothing you can do to
constrain it
it's just
kind of it's just an arbitrary
rotation but what happens is when you
find the symbolic equation at the end
and you simplify it the rotation will go
away
um but that internal step
is is kind of it's completely degenerate
and it depends on the initialization
okay sounds good uh next question is by
john
tenser
uh are you able to separate model uh
form and parameter uncertainties
uh
model so the actual symbolic uncertainty
uh is not well developed in the field at
all so i'm actually trying to do
something like this to have actually
kind of a distribution over equations
rather than one equation but right now
there's not good uh literature on this
oh actually john
commented that you just answered during
the talk um
anyway okay so the next question is by
i'll just mention the constants
themselves yeah uh you can do that with
uh
once you find the symbolic form you can
do regular statistical analysis get the
constant uncertainty
all right sounds good okay next question
is by alex and once you have equations
how difficult is it
in general to understand why they are of
the discovered form and what all the
terms means
i mean
that is a
fundamental question of science and
i
so symbolic regression does not solve it
symbolic regression you can think of the
first step in model discovery
so symbolic regression will find the
empirical relation
you have to understand why that
empirical relation exists so my
algorithm does not solve that step that
is very hard
so so some examples of this
are planck's law
planck's law is actually a function fit
so plank kind of did manual symbolic
regression
and it took the development of quantum
mechanics to explain
why planck's logs is
and actually i think the same thing you
could say for kepler's laws
it took the development of newtonian
mechanics to explain why they
exist okay so that step i think
i think we're a ways away from doing
that with machine learning
yep okay sounds good um next question is
by john can you go into a little more
detail about the learned mask
that you use to disentangle the networks
okay so
in this system
you you basically fix an index of every
planet and moon
and you say to the network
the network actually has its own
variable stored for every single
planet it
it memorizes
uh some variable for every planet in the
moon
during training you allow the model to
back propagate error
to those variables
so it can train
a specific variable for every
uh planet and moon basically
the constraint is
you have to impose f equals mass times
acceleration
the second constraint is you have to
impose
the mass of one planet in your system
so we chose the sun is just one
and then all the masses are relative to
the sun
if you constrain f equals ma
and the mass of the sun is one
then you can actually
find
uh the correct masses so it still has to
learn like
like newton's law of gravity and it has
to find the masses of every single
planet
to
uh fit the dynamics of the system
correctly but it's it's literally
learning
um
unknown variables in the physical system
which it's simultaneously learning how
to model
so i think this approach could be
really interesting to look at for many
different physical systems where we
don't have an understanding of maybe key
uh variables in the system or like
representative course quantities in the
system i think this kind of approach
could be really useful there
okay the next question is by andrei
how difficult would it be to use
gaussian process regression instead of
neural network for this approach
yeah that's a good question
um
so
the
the symbolic regression approach
it's
it's really only
you only use it
um
you you can really only use it when
there's like two or more components of
your neural network that you can kind of
split apart and fit separately
in a gaussian process
i know there's some things like this
like people have done gaussian processes
on image data
but i'm not sure if there's a gaussian
process that would kind of match this
form
it seems it seems conceptually difficult
to work this out with a gaussian process
because
i i think it would kind of be embedded
in your kernel
the the model would kind of be embedded
in your kernel um
i don't know i think i think it would be
conceptually difficult to get that to
work
okay
the next question is by rob so if the
solutions are not unique
are there any wraparound approaches to
step away from those local fits and find
the universal fast beat
so
the solutions well each equation is not
unique
if you put them together at the end so
that the simplified form of the equation
it should work out to the same thing
however
uh many of these problems are just
really hard to solve
and it might find a different
approximation each time
um
in that case
i think it might just be best to run
different initializations until you find
the simplest most accurate expression
um but ultimately symbolic regression
it's a it's a random algorithm
with a genetic algorithm um
so it will find different equations over
time but if you if you run it
asymptotically it should find the same
equations
oh
okay
so somehow somehow you can incorporate
you know you know simplification
the steps in symbolic regression so that
you know at the end
those equivalent equations are
actually give you the same expression
so paiser actually uses that during the
search as well it does a simplification
step every number of steps
and that helps reduce like a lot of
redundancy if it's negative negative
negative x
it'll simplify that
got it okay
and
it can it can do the
the cancellation
between denominator and numerators etc
also
all right um
okay so the
last question i have in the chat room is
by queen kai
he asked what's the effect of input data
size
it depends on
oh
okay so symbolic regression is actually
very good
uh
it's very good at
small data sets so actually paiser
will find the correct equation in a lot
of cases if you have a hundred data
points
for more complex equations you might
need a thousand data points
but a thousand data points is
much much less than required for deep
learning
so generally
symbolic regression is very good at
small data
um
if you're doing the neural network
symbolic regression approach you might
need a lot more data
to train the neural network
okay sounds good
i don't see any more questions but let
me ask that you know this question
related to
the one you just
are you're showing right now um
you said uh you have to introduce the
the constraint of f is equal to ma
you know to train this one
i i don't know is isn't it kind of
cheating because
you know the f is the ma is kind of you
know derived from the
you know
the gravity low um
so f equals m a you can you can find it
classically like on on earth right like
force is proportional to acceleration
yeah mass is proportional to
f over acceleration
so that um you should be able to find
without gravity
the the reason you want to give this
prior knowledge to the model
is that
if you don't
there's no
it's it's completely degenerate
so you could have
f equals m squared a
and then your gravity law is f equals g
m squared m over r squared there's
there's or any other
kind of equation
it's just completely
uh degenerate
and
but if you fix this with with some form
it doesn't even need to be f equals m a
but it'll find the corresponding
newton's law of gravity
um it does still need to find newton's
law of gravity it does this by fitting
a dynamical system
okay
all right sounds good thank you so much
uh miles thanks for having me wonderful
talk and also you did a wonderful job of
you know answering the question during
during the during the talk that that was
very interactive and i i like to see
that um
that's great
okay let's thank our uh speaker miles um
for his wonderful talk and i'm sure you
guys will have a more questions for him
and i'm sure
you can email him directly and he will
be happy to answer those questions right
miles yep yeah definitely
yeah and uh i uh look forward to
visiting at some point yeah
yeah yeah
when when the situation gets better and
i hope that um you will get a lot more
collaborations um you know from the
folks from lone sleeping national that
and also the outside
um you know
the entity uh who has um participate
participated this this seminar series
okay thank you again miles okay thanks a
lot okay okay